so we've called this session the search
for truth I shan't introduce everybody I
think you've met everybody already but
just to name them Michael Levitt Frank
Vil Tech Peter Doherty Sharon Abadi
Steven Chu David gross and Joseph
Stiglitz we've called it the search for
truth because in a way in their own
disciplines that is what unites them
their search for truth but something
else that unites them as Nobel laureates
is the creativity they employ in that
search and so I'd like to begin by
discussing that creativity
let's start by trying to work out what
we mean by the term creativity I'm
looking for some enthusiasm for that
question in their eyes I've got some
good Michael
so creativity is really interesting that
if you ask anyone who's creative where
it comes from
they don't usually know I haven't met
anybody who gets up in the morning and
writes on the list saying things to be
creative of birth and then I don't know
I know I did that items who it seems to
come from walking the dog taking showers
watching TV and doing something which
was actually non-scientific so I think
creativity is a mysterious thing it's
also clear that there are people who
were serial creative people but I think
it's very difficult to know what really
makes I think there's a certain level of
messiness that makes some creative David
well you know unfortunately I think all
of us will agree we have no idea where
creativity comes from and that's quite
unfortunate because if we know we could
teach it and we can't at least we know
ways of encouraging it but not teaching
it but I think it's clearly related to
our illusion that the conscious is
somehow in control of even our thoughts
so I'm often had the experience of
you know in situations like this being
asked provocative questions like you
just ask and then saying something not
in this occasion because I've said it
before I'm saying something that is
novel and new and creative and surprises
me and I said my god that's interesting
I've never heard that before so it comes
from some other place that is not
conscious I have no doubt and these the
brain consists of many parts we
understand now is neuroscience different
modules creativity is located somewhere
there and is a surprise often to the
conscious self so I have no idea what it
is
there are ways however a foster in it
I just justify what conditions do you
find yourself most creative in is there
something you can point to I think what
is what definitely motivates creativity
is concentration
you know just concentrating in a bulldog
fashion on a problem and then that
encourages the unconscious mind you know
the part of our brain that actually does
the work the work away and then come up
with a new idea a new way of looking at
things which but how it happens I have
no idea but concentration is crucial
enthusiasm is growing Frank then Joe
Francis well first my personal
experience my best work I think has come
from immersing myself in some subject
some problem and then getting annoyed
really something something could be
better something or there there have
been unexplored possibilities but I also
resonate with what David said is a very
similar question and a couple of days
ago in a similar venue and said
something along those lines a little
different that our brain indeed consists
of it is a community it's different
pieces that have
different skills different languages and
some of them are logical some of them
are pattern recognition you might say
aesthetic because they want patterns to
click and make sense and I think at
least one important ingredient of
creativity is to get all these guys
communicating and pulling in the same
direction and so that's the process of
mazes people call it intuition you see a
pattern you don't you you kind of
identify a goal but you don't know how
to get there logically and then you
reconstruct some path that doesn't
always work doesn't always exist but
when it exists that's the important
creative process thank you Jeff
yeah I want to just add one one
dimensions which is a questioning of
what you you were taught before or the
standard model so it begins with with
discounting you know a skepticism of and
I also think it begins as I said not
with a question of wanting to answer
something that is wrong with what is the
standard wisdom and then finally one
other ingredient is is this being
exposed to ideas that are very different
and the the process of how those ideas
meet the problem and scepticism is a
very mystical one but you have to be
exposed to these other sources of ideas
so that you can this creative melting
pot occurs how could anyone possibly
think that is often a very positive way
of getting yourself moving I want to get
everybody's views on this one
so Steve first and then you're in Steve
well for me it's a few things a
rebellious streak not willing to accept
things as you hear them but also when I
go into a new fee
that's where I think I get the most
excited I you know unencumbered with
knowledge and this is a very good thing
but I would also link with people who
are experts in the field who were
willing to put up with questions like
what about this and you know they would
have to patient explain to me no that's
not right or yes but someone else has
thought about that and maybe in one or
two percent of the times they will say
hmm let's think some more and so it they
have those collaborators be willing to
put up with you and teach you and
includes my students and postdocs that
is actually for me the most exciting
time and that's why you know i lurk
around thank you
so sharing a body in that manner yet
smack no yeah i love yet yeah dan mr.
Hollyer bloom change our laureate also
watch other well first a man who go get
tougher with Makani now the meaning of
creativity differs from spirit is fear
so it's what how i see creativity is
different from the definitions given by
my esteemed scientist colleagues
monahan more reputable a $1.00 to them
if sign macadam k-rock avenida borrow a
battle over $1 HTML e penny sir I have
always been in pursuit of justice to
that end I have always tried to come up
with ideas for legislation towards
implementation of social justice in
Vermont salafiyyah Tom Rowan before a
judge in the government in the maxim me
hahaha
sadena sky bajo de souza perfect economy
any lung spoken al Abedin me $1 TNG i
become creative when i actually immerse
myself in an idea and to see how for
example can fight injustice bah bahah
Miguel de tucumán
Nikki has a core hi Jeremy shame economy
in a stable homeless all via affordable
Hanuman Hodor I'm underneath the water
so one of the things I do to that end is
to constantly try and be in touch with
homeless or displaced people Vasa resort
Mira and I learned so much from them by
thinking each guest
Zoro miss Lamaze room named Irina by oh
honey because no one can actually speak
about oppression as somebody who's been
oppressed but I think is oh my gosh is
zero
- a de la mere Roja Hal han fei Connie
what both Hajj drama but thou hast Ock
da da dum funny so the key is first to
understand a problem and then draw on
your own experiences and skills in a bit
to find solutions to that problem
I'm Omaha me achieve zubayr Mona's
Kahala via tomorrow ballooning aridaias
COC without them we caught it but one
thing I need to stress is that our
creativity is of no use without
political results you need best arena
for home Bobby Canada won in Berea
Barataria a dolla is Zamani Matawa not
mephibosheth a ke EA ki hukumat a
Democrat Mahad is Rajesh Khanna in other
words the best opinions and the best
legislation can only be effective
towards establishment of justice if
there is a democratic government to
implement those
opinions and ideas thank you thank you
very much indeed and again it brings out
the ideas of concentration and exposure
to other influences which is so
important and has been brought out by
others
Peter you haven't spoken on this one yet
Oh creativity in science I think most of
it's been said often happens discovery
insight novelty often happens when you
come into a field from outside so you're
not trapped by the perceptions of the
field which can be satisfying I mean I
think we all know scientists are
actually terrified of discovering
anything because it would put them
outside the norm and they feel very
uncomfortable but you can't be that sort
of personality creativity can come
Francis Crick and Jim Watson two very
different personalities different
backgrounds talked and talked and talked
backwards and forwards backwards and
forwards annoyed everybody else dragged
stuff out from this person and that
person stole everything and made a
synthesis very creative Crick after he
and Watson split up did the same thing
with sydney brenner you've got three
Nobel Prize winners there so
creativity's right across society and
all sorts of different ways and all
sorts of different people I think it the
creative person cannot offer me an
extremely annoying person they're
annoying to be around I see things
differently from the way that everybody
else sees them makes them very
discomforting they're not particularly
like they're social outcasts at times
creativity's they get the curse of
creativity yes you've mentioned the
immersion concentration how important in
your own lives has creativity been as
opposed to just good hard work that's
one for the graduate students to listen
to right
who wants to take that Peter oh well a
lot of breakthroughs in biomedical
science actually come from better
technology and and we we'd have to ask
the answer
thank you physicists often for that and
the chemists and all the rest because
you're worrying about a problem you're
seeing a problem and you're not seeing
it because you don't see clearly enough
so so it's often is the biblical saying
you know it's real glass exactly we see
impact and then you see better and when
you see better you understand better and
you measure better because science is
about measurement and if you're talking
about truth you know that these are
universals that we've talking about the
future of truth today well basically the
truth for science hasn't changed at all
in 400 years I mean the basically the
mechanisms are the same the rules are
the same the product is the same so that
that that that that is the future
science it's when it's the future of
truth in the broader context that
weakens we're concerned about so I
actually try to avoid hard work when
things look when things look complicated
and difficult to that's often a sign
that there's a different way a better
way to do it there's another there are a
few as I said ways of promoting
creativity and and I think Steve talked
about one of them which is going to it
going into a new field or posing a new
question which is not necessarily yet a
discovery but just approaching a new
question that most people ignore because
they think it's too hard or because it
is too hard and and so empty territory
is a great place for creativity it's
very easy to come up with the first I'd
good ideas in the field and once
breakthroughs are then made the easy
ones the crowd rushes in
then it gets harder and harder yeah
science is also over 400 years developed
enormous Lee we now have millions of
scientists there used to be hundreds and
it's so one lesson - I try to tell my
students and give them hints as to how
to be successful as a creative
productive scientist is to go where the
crowds aren't yeah
Steve sorry Mike okay so just very
quickly what Peter said majal career
I've been trying to develop instruments
invent new instruments and because I
realize there's so many more people
smarter than me and but if you are the
first to look under a rock with a new
instrument you don't have to be smart
and and so that and so continuing just
you know okay what new instrument what
new method or what new technique or what
new now nanoprobe it's and so I try to
teach people who are equally incompetent
and dumb that invents a new instrument
invent a new method and then the world
opens up Michael you are going to do so
I guess like Frank most of my work has
been theoretical and just thinking back
as I have I've lost a couple of minutes
I think most of the time you're just
working hard but I would guess I
probably had I don't know five or six
good ideas in my life so firstly it's an
amazing feeling it's it's a high that is
really incredible when you get it
sometimes they don't work out maybe have
had ten ideas and half of them didn't
work out but I think in some ways it's
one of the reasons why being a scientist
is so great to have an idea to feel it's
gonna be okay and then so you work it
out and it comes out to be okay so I
think in some ways creative ideas are
the very heart about the best part about
side
thank you Joe well I'm an economist and
some of the people here would add out
the use of the word science for what I
you know and doubt whether we should
have a Nobel Prize for oh no you do say
that but but I want to make two points
one I agree very strongly that
concentration is important and in
something some kind of hard work but
sometimes people who work very hard
don't you know because they're looking
in the wrong place and this is where I
think economics is different from the
other subjects which is it's not usually
a new instrument that you know our new
data set so if you take say a problem
like inequality it was obviously sitting
there it was that the ideology was so
strong that nobody wanted to talk about
or the question of the existence of
imperfect information that was a
question where they didn't know how to
think about this mathematically and
we're afraid to go there so in both of
those cases it was it was not a new
discovery but the facts were obvious but
it was really the the willingness or the
saying this is probably important and
you ought to concentrate your mind to
figure out whether it is or not and how
it affects our discipline thank you
Sharon it strikes me that hard work is
at the very core of the achievements
you've been able to
AlphaTech a chorus your visage and Mahal
Manohar Moffatt easily a well again we
go it's of course it's obvious that hard
work is necessary for any kind of
achievement
man again in Safari kisaku Sheba is the
heart of man but this kind of
hard work and diligence must have must
be targeted is the motor mark is
officially through your own qaddafi care
they studied my beheaded on Hadar pH is
a heckuva stay in over half inch I did
worship and so you have to concentrate
on that goal and of course it would be
good if that is an innovative idea and
it's a new idea there is name on catalpa
physioline image to show this when it
can be turn up again what a Stefani I
said on her yech half for hey Dom miss
about home of the left a coruña in my
field of work many books have been
written but regrettably and a lot of
them are constantly repeating the same
things on sugar more handmade asking a
veteran or aramid what is important is
to come up with a new idea and figure in
no that Assad a hollow as is that a
physical channel Rishabha Horschel on
care scientist came with us along with
some enjoy much movie something
approachable back spoken of as so year
ahamkara number four season a sir - for
scientific new ideas I'm glad I'm not a
physicist and I don't need to worry
about that kind of new ideas so you can
ask my and it's team colleagues about
that here thank you
ok well we're running very close to the
end
let's change tack slightly we've had a
meeting about the future of true
and I think it might be appropriate to
end by say a skew whether you feel
hopeful for the future of truth or not
you're nodding Michael does that mean
you are I'm definitely optimistic as I
said before I think the changing the
fact the Western world is becoming the
whole world at least in terms of ideals
of capitalism and wanting to invent
things and improve standards of living I
think it's really hopeful because it
means that no one has a monopoly of
everything Frank very optimistic because
I think the nature of the truth is that
it builds and accumulates whereas errors
fall away so in the long run truth will
win I've been fine minute reality can't
be denied it's just a matter of how the
process of how you get there the process
that we use in science to get there
don't don't really change and I don't I
think within science that we've had
certain issues with fraud and so forth I
think that modern technology really
defeats much of that and we're not gonna
see the problem the problem is to get
our political and masters and broader
society to accept those trees before
they become really dangerous right thank
you so at the point of having three
scientists views we're optimistic nobody
I am there cometh unabashedly evil will
be shafted
the future of civilization is going
towards progress failures is like you
lose the row your boat battery Bashar
yet Mina Milan at the fall of the day
there are many things that were merely
dreams for Humanity and now they have
actually materialized chandrasana Raja
on Rico so vodka Donovan's so but like
I'm a nobody misery Yemen salt solutions
fellows and I'm here in a lot of
evolution since everyone else has talked
it on the United States except me let me
say a few words about the you us to make
sure that there's been justice
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
um become a fraud there Davis if his
safety post also tabooed and while on me
being in care
praise Joe yet Nevada as someone after
other kaydessa feet-first very some who
show their John listeners can safely
push their hemay Amidala - bad Megan
does on wrangling who's there Todd if
you gonna possibly need charity mattone
mattone a piece of toast oh
there was a time in the United States
when no African American had any freedom
and then suddenly an African American
became President of the United States
and very popular and then after that he
was succeeded by a white American yet we
can see how this white American is now
being criticized and that African
American is being praised by a body that
is heaviest is okay EMU's madam arroyos
that I am dead to half of our possible
so that is why a lot of things that
today we see just as a dream or bound to
materialize in the future thank you
that's a hard act to follow Steve
Buerger so yes some optimistic
scientists have to be optimistic because
we fail most of the time because we're
trying to do some new things and so and
I you know to be brief I think choose
well Trump Trump you know the AI
scientists are generally optimistic
sometimes however they are pessimistic
but most of the time they are optimistic
I've pondered that and I've come to the
conclusion that partly that's because
science is not easy it's difficult and
they optimist simply the pessimist
simply quit so the only people who
survive and succeed are the after this
so I am very much an optimist I believe
that science will survive Trump of
course and truth will ultimately prevail
because what else is there - so but we
should be wary of overly being overly
optimistic even with rock obama and so
on humanity has gone through declines in
the past in the recent past in the last
two millennium it's not always been
progress the Roman Empire fell apart in
Europe and led to a thousand years of
dark ages and and non truth so we should
be careful and vigilant and make sure
that we Trump Trump
it's it's okay it's hard to be over
overly optimistic if you're a British
just at the moment you know
well economists are known as the dismal
science and well I do agree that over
the long run to throw will prevail
Keynes had this very famous statement of
in the long run we're all dead
and I am a little bit with David here
saying worried about the the battle that
is going to be going on over the
immediate future and I don't think it is
obvious so that that what will happen
and unless there is really very active
opposition the the words of whether
trumpet trumpet or not is really still
open in the air thank you very much
indeed
okay sadly that is it we're out of time
I would like to thank us our partners
who make all this possible that's Carl
Burnett a be the city of Gothenburg
Ericsson and I always dread this one the
Radian vestra Yertle and also our
supporters in stainless stiffs awesome
that's also difficult for reverberate I
would particularly like to thank all our
participants today and our assembled
Nobel laureates and also especially you
the audience for being here thank you
all and see you in Stockholm in 2018
[Applause]